donc vous avez envie de de fonder une
famille tout à fait disons que ça c'est
c'est c'est mon prochain challenge
Jean-Luc vous vous êtes jeune vous avez
26 ans et demi vous êtes célibataire
vous êtes installé il y a 5 ans
maintenant près de Toulouse dans le
gerse dans une une exploitation vous
faites du maïs du soja de l'aquaculture
donc vous élevez des des poissons des
écrevis c'est vrai je suis installé donc
depuis le 1er janvier 90 en société avec
avec mes parents mais en dehors de de
vos parents non non alors le le travail
est en commun et euh l'habitation n'est
pas en commun si c'est ça que vous
voulez savoir oui oui tout à fait c'est
vrai nous nous sommes démarqués les uns
et les autres et c'est vrai aussi ça ça
va dans le sens du témoignage précédent
hein oui c'est très important voilà on
travaille ensemble mais il n'est pas
nécessaire de vivre ensemble hein bon
c'est c'est normal et ça se comprend
d'autant plus bon il y a toujours une
génération d'écart et qui dit génération
d'écart dit aussi des conflits de
génération bon si on veut une intimité
et cetera bon on a besoin de d'être chez
soi quoi point à la ligne alors pour
vous c'était vous l'avez dit une
vocation donc ce qui veut dire que vous
avez fait des études pour euh pour être
agriculteur vous avez tout fait pour ça
ben oui très très jeune donc j'ai pensé
à devenir agriculteur parce que c'était
un fait un métier qui me qui me plaisait
le contact avec la nature et cetera et
donc c'est vrai j'ai fait un bac des
primes donc qui est un bac scientifique
mais avec des matières agricoles plus
des sciences économi et ensuite ce ce
bac a été suivi donc d'un BTS technique
agricole gestion d'entreprise depuis 5
ans vous êtes installé quelle vie vous
avveit est-ce que ça a été difficile
cette installation ben disons que euh
elle a été difficile oui mais euh
c'était quelque chose qui avait été
prévu euh bon lorsqu'on s'installe on
fait des études prévisionnelles en
matière donc d'argent en matière
financière et bon créer une structure
comme nous avons créé enfin avec mes
parents ça se fait pas du jour au L
demain euh nous avons beaucoup investi
et on savait qu'on avait 3 qu années de
de difficile à passer et que après bon
ça ça irait beaucoup mieux en terme
d'échéance ça on aurait des des
réductions importantes et ça irait
beaucoup mieux vous vivez avec et vous
avez vécu pendant ces 5 années avec à
peu près combien par mois bon ben disons
que pendant ces 5in dernières années
enfin pendant les trois dernières années
je me suis on a pu se verser qu'un tout
petit salaire de l'ordre de 1500 francs
par mois donc qui euh oui enfin qui qui
souvenait à tous nos besoins voilà parce
que une fois payé les annuités donc
rembourser les les engagements qu'on
avait pris vis-à-vis de nos créanciers
il ne restait pas grand chose pour vivre
donc on prélevait on prélevait le
minimum ce qui est considéré d'ailleurs
en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et qui est en dessous du donc
du RMI qui est de l'ordre 2300 franc par
mois oui Marie Paul vous vivez vous
votre famille avec environ combien par
mois 3000 francs 3000 francs pour pour 5
pour
5 mais comment vous faites on fait ce
qu'on peutc de cuisine ouais disons que
onachète pas grand-chose
ouais comme dit Marie Paul un
agriculteur en fait la seule une des
satisfactions qu'on peut avoir c'est
qu'on Mura jamais de fa il est certain
com on manquera peut-être de loisirs
enfin ou de sortir au cinéma ou quoi que
ce soit mais a priori on ne Murra jamais
de fin est-ce que ça vous manque les
loisirs non pas du tout je je vois pas
pour je je vois pas pourquoi les loisirs
me manqueraient dans la mesure o j'
quand même eu pas mal puisque j'ai fait
beaucoup de sport donc je vous l'ai dit
je me suis épanoui dans le sport dans le
rugby dans la moto continuez en
parallèle euh oui alors le sport j'ai
arrêté donc lors de mon installation
pour raisons professionnelles parce
qu'on peut pas on peut pas tout
concilier enfin les entraînements de
rugby et des blessure le dimanche et
cetera et avec donc la vie
professionnelle et le respect
d'engagement financier bon et puis
d'autres raisons mon professionneles
m'ont poussé à reprendre il y a pas si
longtemps que ça voilà et quelle raison
euh alors ce sont des raisons comment
dire c'est c'est pour canaliser des
énergies
débordantes pourqui vous ayez des
problèmes de violence non je suis dans
temperm pas agressif non mais euh il je
je Bou ouais je bouillonne assez vous
vous avez vous en êtes sans doute rendu
compte un petit peu un peu voilà et bon
et ben j'aime bien le défoulement
physique pas aller taper sur les gensin
je suis pas comme ça je suis un gentil
hein je suis un gentil non mais j'aime
bien aller me défouler physiquement quoi
passer un dimanche à à oublier tous tous
les soucis de la semaine et repartir bon
ben un temps soit peu épuisé
physiquement et repartir serin moral
vous éprouvez un véritable plaisir
lorsque vous travaillez oui euh et mais
pas pas pas un plaisir qui confine à la
passion comme le disait tout à l'heure
François ça ça vous a énervé si je je
non ça m'a pas énervé du tout du tout
euh je je pense être au moins aussi
passion niquel sauf sauf que je comme je
vous l'ai dit je le répète euh je ne
couche pas avec mon tracteur euh ni avec
ma TER quoi alors que elle elle était
carrément mariée alors qui vous avez
envie d'épouser parce que ça c'est une
véritable question vous allez vous avez
envie plutôt de rencontrer une une femme
qui soit quelqu'un qui connaisse qui
soit de de la campagne qui connaisse le
métier ou plutôt quelqu'un qui vientent
de la ville comme Marie Paul bon très
certainement quelqu'un qui vient
d'ailleurs mais qui est qui a qui a une
ouverture d'esprit très
importante ceci ceci dit je suis pas
quand même venu à cette émission pour
pas une petite annau une petite Ann vous
êtes peut-être d'ailleurs finiancé non
non non du tout non je suis célibataire
là depuis 3 mois bon c'est c'est une
situation à laquelle je n'aspire pas que
je n'entends pas péréniser et qui
j'espère sera le plus éphémère possible
h donc vous avez envie de de fonder une
famille tout à fait disons que ça c'est
c'est c'est mon prochain challenge ah
oui voilà
c'est mon prochain challenge disons que
j'ai fait des choses j'ai on a créé une
entreprise qui s'est développé très
rapidement qui aujourd'hui est en passe
don de de nous satisfaire d'un point de
vue rentabilité bon aujourd'hui s'il y a
pas de grand changement je j'espère
pouvoir vivre dignement en fin du
travail que je fais quoi sauf que et
j'espère aussi ça c'est une autre chose
pouvoir m'aménager encore plus de temps
de libre et donc forcer un petit peu
moins sur sur la ferme pour pouvoir
consacrer du temps peut-être à quelqu'un
que j'aimerais mais aussi pour consacrer
du temps à à d'autres gens parce que je
suis pas de nature égoïste et euh j'aime
bien rendre service aux autres en
général c'est pour ça que je fais du
syndicalisme c'est pour ça aussi que je
souhaite m'impliquer dans une autre
aventure qui est qui est une
aventure un petit peu plus politique au
niveau donc de la collectivité enfin ou
de de la mairie de l'île Jourdin en tout
cas elle a intérêt à être à la hauteur
hein votre fiancé votre futur fiancé on
sens vous allez lui demander beaucoup
non je j'attends beaucoup mais je donne
beaucoup mais est-ce que vous auriez
envie qu'elle partage avec vous les
justement le le travail de de
l'exploitation ou qu'elle est un métier
complètement différent je préférerai oui
je préférerai je souhaiteraiis que un
métier complètement différent tout à
fait même si c'est plus compliqué euh à
vivre parce que ça doit être plus
difficile non pour peut-être pour se
comprendre pour les horaires non je
pense pas euh les paysans ont des
horaires qui ne sont pas rigides et donc
on est à même et si si la personne avec
qui l'on est comprend tout à fait ça on
est à même en même de de de partager
beaucoup de temps avec elle quoi et en
conséquent je sais pas sans aller parler
de fonctionnaire ou quoi mais enfin
quelqu'un qui fait ses 8hur par jour
après il est libre et puis nous on peut
on peut lui donner aussi quoi hein B
voilors d' passer une petite annonce
sans que vous le vouliez ouais ouais ça
me ça me gêne un petit peu parce que ce
genre de petit annos en revenant chez
moi je vais me faire brancher au
possible je
choisirit non non non non pas pas
brancher par des filles faire brancher
par par mes camarades parce
que ouais non non qui sont qui sont de
très joyeux luron et qui qui n'en
loupent pas une d'ailleurs hein voilà
oui oui pardonoui je simplement dire
qu'il y a pas il y a il y a à la
campagne il y a pas pire que la solitude
c'est la solitude la plus terrible il a
parfaitement raison quand il dit qu'il
veut pas rester tout seul c'est c'est
c'est horrible à vivre et il y a des
gens qui le supportent pas donc c'est la
solitude ressenti comme frustration qui
est quelque chose d'horrible et non pas
la solitude en soi moi je suis très
contente d'être toute seuleou ouais tout
à fait j'étais sûr que elle a raison de
réagir comme ça parce que il y a il y a
si c aille j'étais aussi content de
passer mes dimanches tout seul
aujourd'hui je le suis moins mais je les
passe pas tout seul hein d'ailleurs je
rends ici hommage un petit peu à un
camarade qui n'a plus supporté cette
solitude et qui lui a a tenté réussi à
mettre fin à ses jours est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup de tentative de
suicide dans le monde deagriculture il
paraît que certaines statistiques disent
que que oui je sais pas s'il y en a plus
qu'ailleurs euh moi je crois que au
niveau des tentatives de suicide ce qui
se dit aussi euh c'est qu'il y en a
beaucoup chez les jeunes je crois de de
18 à 25 ans je crois que c'est ça Nonin
au niveau statistique moi je suis pas
persuadé qu'il y en ait plus chez les
agriculteurs enfin chez les
peut-être alors tous les trois vous
représentez trois générations d'âge donc
différents Marcelle qu'est-ce qui vous
différencie et qu'est-ce qui vous
lit ce qui nous lit c'est c'est c'est le
plus facile à voir c'est le fait de de
vivre avec avec la terre ou avec les
animaux en d'une
façon disons on établit quand même même
si c'est pas c'est pas mariage on a
quand même des rapports de d'amour avec
le travail avec ce que nous faisons
ça ça m'a paru assez certain et ce qui
nous ce qui nous sépare c'est que bon
moi j'ai vécu disons à à l'ancienne mais
en ayant parfaitement conscience que
j'étais la fin d'une série en quelque
sorte
euh la charnière Mar a raté un peu la la
charnière et puis voilà le représentant
de des jeunes agriculteurs chez moi ils
font ça
avec sur sur moins de surface et puis
ils font autre chose ils font de
l'élevage c'est différent mais sinon ce
sont des gens qui vont partir en sachant
d'où ils viennent et en sachant où ils
vont et puis finalement c'est pas si mal
et en même temps ce sont des gens qui
aiment on a en commun le côté
passionnelamour du métier et l'amour du
métier et puis maintenant on on a de
différents euh les nécessités
économiques et donc les la notion de
chef d'entreprise oui
voilà cette notion qu'on nous impose de
chef d'entreprise oui c'est c'est une
évolution imposée en fait ou nécessaire
on ne réussit pas dans le métier si si
derrière tout ça il y a pas une
formation et enfin un niveau général
acquis euh qui permettent donc
d'affronter ces difficultés là hein de
gestion d'entreprise et cetera quoi hein
parce que tous les jours tous les jours
et on compte tous les jours c'est
exagéré peut-être mais les chiffres il
ils sont là c'est une réalité
quotidienne pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche bonjour c'est Mireille Duma vous
apparaissez dans l'une de nos vidéos
vous désirez témoigner de nouveau
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter par mail
à l'adresse qui s'écrit ci-dessous